the uh
the grift continues actually it's not
even really the griff it's more the is
it the cover-up
uh we now have
a new report
that the gift records
for donald trump and mike pence they're
just missing
we they're gone the state department
says
nbc news reporting the executive office
of the president
did not submit information about gifts
received by trump and his family from
foreign leaders in the year 2020
this is a uh this is quite literally how
you track
the emoluments adherence to the
emoluments clause of the constitution
you know when we talk about
people in office receiving gifts and
things of value from foreigners this was
an issue during the russia investigation
this is how we track it this is how we
hold them accountable for 2020 the
records are just missing the article
goes on to say the state department says
it is unable to compile a complete and
accurate accounting of gifts presented
to trump and other officials during his
last year in office the data is missing
from the white house
in a report to be published in the
federal register next week
the department says the executive office
of the president did not submit
information about gifts received by
trump and his family from foreign
leaders in 2020 wow
it also says the general services
administration didn't submit information
about gifts given to mike pence and
staffers
the state department said it sought the
missing information from where from the
national archives and records
administration and the gsa but was told
that quote potentially relevant records
are not available because of access
restrictions to retired records
wow
the report notes the lack of gift
information could be related to internal
oversights
as the protocol office neglected to
submit the request prior to bubba
when the trump administration ended
however it also noted there has been a
quote this is like the understatement of
the century there's been a lack of
adequate record-keeping pertaining to
diplomatic gifts
during trump's white house reign i mean
listen
maybe check mar-a-lago for those records
as well i don't know
um and now there are there there's the
reaction oh everybody does this this
this so every administration does this
actually no go back to the guardian
report from 2018
we learned that the saudis gave barack
obama and his aides jewels
worth thousands of dollars according to
ex-advisor ben rhodes
they got quote suitcases full of jewels
on a 2009 trip and they were immediately
turned over to the state protocol office
no missing records no question marks we
know exactly what went on this is this
is a big difference here between the two
administrations and you know it
it's one of these things where
individually well
the documents that trump ate he ate
because they thought they tasted like
doritos and so you don't have to worry
about that and the documents he flushed
thought they might have e coli on them
and trump wanted to get him out of there
and then the documents that he brought
to mar-a-lago
right i'm kidding around about the
explanations but that there's
individually you can say this was an
oversight and that was an accident and
then trump ripped him up because that's
what he's used to but we taped them back
together
but then you take the totality and you
you have to say this is a pattern and
one of the things that investigators
look at you know we talk about there are
crimes that are really difficult to
prove because they go to state of mind
i know this is like a broken record but
perjury
people lie in court all the time
and sometimes the lies are really hard
to prove like for example there's a
technique where you can go in when
you're supposed to give
testimony and your your
you testify in court and you're asked
about things and you don't want to lie
you don't want to give a false answer
so you say you don't recall now
sometimes saying you don't recall can
get you into trouble because good
lawyers that are prepared for false i
don't recalls have a line of questioning
and they have records and they can
actually show you did recall when
someone else asked you about it or
whatever so say lying about i don't
recall has its risks but sometimes for a
well-prepared witness
dishonest i don't recalls
can get you out of trouble and you are
lying you do recall and it's very hard
to prove and that's why you rarely see
perjury charges okay that's just one
example
uh when it comes to
um
sedition for example sedition and maybe
i can even pull up
um
the definition conduct or speech meant
to incite people to rebel against an
authority okay you know john so with
sedition there's an aspect of saying
well it's not only what you said but it
was your intent in getting people to
rebel against the established order or
the government or what these things can
be can be difficult to prove but context
and a pattern
is something that can be used to try to
show
what was in the mindset of an individual
and when you see all the things trump
knew were wrong right he said hillary is
irresponsible with the
with sensitive information and private
email and not keeping records so he knew
that these things were wrong to do
and then trump rips up records eats
records flushes records steals records
spills secrets to a russian spy
recruiter in the oval office that we got
from our ally israel you see the pattern
of him doing things which we know he
knew they were wrong because he
criticized hillary for doing them
then it's hard to say that this isn't a
pattern and that this is deliberate
action right i mean it it just is what
it is
will there be consequences probably not
uh but i do have a voicemail that goes
to that let's go to that next
science has shown us that lowering your
body temperature at night improves sleep
in many ways our sponsor chilly sleep
creates systems that cool down your bed
promoting deeper higher quality sleep it
also just feels great i use it at home
i'd recommend it to anyone and i've
recommended it to some friends who now
use it as well chili sleeps product the
uhler the cube and the doc pro
they're all water-based temperature
controlled pads that fit onto your
existing mattress you can keep your bed
as low as 55 degrees as hot as 115
degrees i like 60 their new doc pro
sleep system has double the cooling
power of other models five times the
cooling contact whisper quiet you can
control it with your phone it's awesome
with chilly sleep there's no more
feeling hot at night no more sweating
cooling your bed down like this is
amazing you really have to try it for
yourself when you go to chilisleep.com
pacman you'll get thirty percent off of
the uhler and
sleep systems and 10 off the new dock
pro this offer is only for my audience
the link is down below